Google Fiber starts with internet speeds
up to a gigabit a second it's internet
100 times faster than what most
Americans have today is my internet so
fast
so
fast remember Google Fiber way back in
2010 Google sought to win the broadband
internet Market by introducing
revolutionary internet speeds of one
gigabit per second they were looking to
achieve this by introducing a fiber
optic technology to the General market
this was a quite able to move as the
Legacy players like atnt Comcast and the
charter had such a stronghold on the
market but if anyone was capable of
taking on these Giants it was someone
like Google things started off strong
for Google Fiber as they launched in
Kansas followed by Texas Utah and
Tennessee it seemed like Google was
doing it they were putting Legacy
players to shame as people flocked to
Google's offerings but this success did
not last too long in the mid-2010s ATT
would start hitting back and they would
Flex just how powerful they truly were
while Google Fiber was expanding City by
City ATT would announce a nationwide
rollout covering it dozens of cities and
they weren't bluffing either given that
they would spend an eye-watering
140 billion dollars to make that Vision
a reality this was obviously a massive
morale hit for Google and they would
soon announce that they were cutting
their fibrous stuff by half to make
things worse Atia and the charter would
start sabotaging Google Fiber by suing
them and the pulling political favors it
seems like all this pressure was too
much for CEO Craig Barrett to handle as
he would step down during the worst of
it but the nail in the coffin it didn't
come to the Late 2010s by which point at
T had finished much of their critical
rollout suddenly Google was no longer
introducing fiber to new areas many of
the cities that they were expanding to
already had fiber thanks to atnt and it
didn't help that atnt was not only
cheaper but more reputable from the
General Public perspective with no
choice left Google would actually begin
to leave certain cities that they had
pioneered like Louisville Kentucky since
then we haven't heard much news from
Google apparently they're still
expanding and have plans of moving into
five new States but it's not clear how
much of this will come to fruition
especially with the recession
objectively it looks like Google bit off
way more than they could chew and that
they got put in their place but what if
I told you that Google knew that this
would happen from the very beginning and
this wasn't their worst case scenario it
was actually the scenario that they were
betting on so here's why Google Fiber
was actually Google's most successful
failure
foreign
to understand why Google entered the
Broadband Market as a whole we'll have
to take a look back at this data fiber
internet before Google you see it fiber
optic data transmission is by no means a
new technology it was actually
demonstrated way back in 1965 by a
German physicist named Manfred borner
and that NASA I even used fiber optic
cables in the cameras that they sent to
the moon at first the technology wasn't
commercially viable given that it
required an extremely intensive
manufacturing process high quality
Optical fibers could barely be
manufactured at 2 meters per second but
by 1983 this would be increased all the
way to 50 meters per second this
actually meant that producing Fiber
Optic Cables was cheaper than producing
traditional copper cables but despite
these revolutionary findings the
broadband internet would head in a
completely different direction dial up
internet if you're not familiar with
dialogue it consists of calling a
specified phone number and indicating
internet connection through your phone
cable this result did an extremely slow
speeds of 56 kilobits per second or even
lower but this was actually for the best
when you're introducing a new technology
you won't reduce barriers to adoption
buy as much as possible so the fact that
internet could work through phone lines
that already existed around the world
was a massive win but over time this
quickly turned into the internet's
biggest inhibitor as well you see isps
figured why create a new infrastructure
if we don't have to and this led to the
Broadband industry becoming fixated onto
offerings DSL and the cable DSL was
offered by telephone providers and aimed
to leverage phone lines as much as
possible meanwhile cable internet was
offered by cable providers and and to
leverage cable lines as much as possible
there was also a third medium of
Internet which sought to leverage
satellite infrastructure but this never
really took off resulting in a dual play
between DSL and the cable providers
sometimes DSL providers made some sort
of advancement and Edge dot cable
providers other times cable providers
made some sort of advancement and
entered out DSL providers but neither
was radically better than the other also
these so-called advancements were by no
means breakthroughs they usually
consisted of improvements from one
megabit per second to 2 megabits per
second or 2 megabits per second to 4
megabits per second while these were
admittedly 2x increases they were
nothing in comparison to the 100 500 at
1000x increases that were possible
through fiber there was a sort of
unspoken agreement between the DSL
providers and the cable providers that
they would both stick to their lanes and
not do anything to ambitious and given
that no startup could challenge their
dominance these isps pretty much set the
rules but no one really cared either
virtually no one needed speeds of 300 at
200 or even 100 megabits per second in
the 1990s and 2000s I mean all people
were doing with the internet was forums
emails and light social media but all of
this would change after 2010.
while isps had stuck to linear
improvements companies based on the
internet were growing exponentially and
so was their Need for Speed likely the
two best examples of this are streaming
and gaming 4K TVs have become a dirty
cheap and basically every streaming
platform offers 4K options whether it be
YouTube or Netflix but the biggest
bottleneck to making 4K streaming a
reality was broadband internet to stream
480p it you only need a 1.1 megabits per
second but to stream 4K you needed 20
megabits per second and that's if you're
the only person using the internet in
your household if you live with your
family or roommates you need speeds of
50 or 100 megabits per second so that
everyone can use the internet
comfortably the same thing applies to
gaming as well given that the industry
was moving away from physical copies to
download these new 100 or 150 gigabyte
games you need a much faster speed than
4 megabits per second at that rate it
would literally take days to download
these games but at least that's a
one-time problem to actually enjoy many
of these online games you need reliable
ping which simply wasn't feasible
through the traditional offerings
clearly it was time for disruption but
isps weren't gonna disrupt themselves so
enter Google's incentives for radically
improving internet speeds were obvious I
mean they're the largest internet
company in the world if anyone has ticks
in the internet becoming better it's
them and it's not just for mindlessly
watching YouTube videos in 4k that right
there was probably the least of their
concerns their real concern was
productive applications like video calls
through Google hangouts virtual
classrooms through Chrome OS and the
Google classroom and most importantly
the cloud through Google Cloud if they
wanted any of these applications to take
off they they needed isps to ditch DSL
and cable and switched to fiber or
something even better and as a result
they would step up to the plate with
Google Fiber and they went straight for
the big guns they didn't even bother
aiming for numbers with units of MBA
they went straight for one gigabit per
second keep in mind this was during a
time when most people were struggling to
get speeds of one megabit per second so
speeds of one gigabit per second that
were very much unfathomable at least for
me for Google these speeds were nothing
given that it took a lot more horsepower
to run their massive data centers
networks and servers for perspective
Google needed one petabit per second or
one million gigabits per second
troubander Jupiter network based data
centers way back in 2015. who knows how
much they need today so theoretically
speaking offering fiber shouldn't have
been that difficult in terms of
Technology Google just had to make a
fraction of what they were capable of
available to the end customers but as we
so often find it Theory it doesn't
always translate to reality
that didn't matter though because they
had no intention of actually overtaking
said isps but wait a minute if Google
was gonna get into the Broadband game
they might as well try to grow a new
sector and displace the Legacy players
right well the answer is actually
absolutely not from a financial
perspective here's the thing it cost a t
140 billion dollars to accomplish a
semi-nation-wide fiber rollout and
that's despite their Decades of
experience hundreds of billions of
dollars worth of existing infrastructure
and Telecommunications being their
primary focus and business if Google
were to try to achieve this from scratch
it would cost them 200 or 300 billion
dollars especially given Google's top of
the market salaries but even if we
assumed that they were somehow able to
get it done for a hundred billion
dollars it still makes no sense you see
it Google's entire market cap back in
2010 was only 300 to 400 billion dollars
this means that if they actually took
fiber seriously they would essentially
be betting a third of their entire net
worth on this market and much of this
would probably have to be paid for using
debt that itself is a pretty bad
situation but it gets exponentially
worse when you consider opportunity cost
take YouTube for example there's no
official market cap for YouTube but I
think we can all agree that YouTube is
worth at least 100 billion dollars but
do you know what Google paid for YouTube
a mere 1.65 billion an even better
example is Android again I think we can
all agree that Android is worth at least
100 billion dollars but do you know what
Google paid for Android a disgusting 50
million so with a hundred billion
dollars Google can either bet on 60
potential YouTubes 2 000 potential
Androids or they can try to challenge
ATT and to take over the Broadband
Market even if Google Fiber grew to
become the entire size of a t that's
only 135 billion dollars in other words
Google can either bet on creating 60
YouTubes 2000 Androids or one ATT for
obvious reasons even a fool would not
choose the atnt option and that's why
Google created fiber knowing that it
would likely never blow up but that
didn't matter Google Fiber didn't need
to blow up to be successful it just
needed to threaten the monopolies of
isps and that's exactly what it did
foreign
PS fired back so hard at that they've
actually started to out offer Google
Fiber Google only offers up to 2
gigabits per second while agent offers
up to 5 gigabits per second granted it
is quite expensive the same thing can be
said about Verizon XFinity Spectrum
CenturyLink Optimum and basically any
other ISP that you can think of we
should also mention that previously
Unthinkable breakthroughs have suddenly
come about regarding cable internet
somehow the same cable providers are now
able to provide speeds of up to 500
megabits per second for the same price
in the end Google Fiber was never meant
to become a household name when it comes
to broadband internet even if Google was
capable of accomplishing something like
this it simply wouldn't be worth the
cost effort and the time required to
actually make that Vision a reality
however what Google could accomplish
with relatively low effort was reignite
this stagnant ISP industry and looking
at the results it appears that Google
Fiber was a bigger success than their
Wildest Dreams did you realize what game
Google was playing with fiber comment
that down below also drop a like if
you're glad that isps are finally doing
something and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community such
as future video ideas and it consider
subscribing to see more questions at
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one